this is the new european bauhaus
a movement that wants to shape the
beautiful sustainable
and inclusive living spaces of tomorrow
a project of hope that brings a cultural
dimension the green deal
and wants to accelerate the transition
of the built environment
too ambitious not if we do it together
that's the plan until summer 2021
we collect your examples ideas and
challenges
to re-imagine future ways to live
together while protecting our planet
your inputs will be translated into
community support
calls for proposals and funding
opportunities including prizes
as from september 2021 we will launch
pilot projects in different eu countries
we will promote
knowledge sharing and we'll bring our
community to the next level
the new european bauhaus has a global
dimension
and the movement shall spread to all
europe and beyond
are you a designer architect engineer
scientist student entrepreneur or
creative mind
then join the movement and be part of
the new european bauhaus